you are killing oh you are pronouncing I
love you got to do sweet I love so much
love happening I love it you're going to
leave it so good if you haven't be able
to turn the bar cool alright don't even
let me in but then I'm like they gave me
this to him look at you now that's it
like he would have people throw the word
with Matt thank you I don't know why I
just got a book it's an excited about
and I'm hoping us and I just like you
know come casual world domination pick
things up ah yeah I don't first people
for support it is for some of the
pendant and for some of the nominated
and it's a summer one yeah I'm very
excited for you coming from Canada we
have a couple of yeah a couple of
Canadian nominees tonight new straight
to weekend Olympic era yup all people on
fans oh okay yes anyone you're really
excited to see
I've had the honor of meeting both Drake
and elicit a before I've never been to
often close with the weekend who I think
is extremely talented so I'm excited to
be around all of that energetic first
sir fifth harmony is going to be here
performing first time as a quartet I
know they're looking for someone else
maybe
well I are yet detective Dino knows like
girls you see someone wiling on the
audience like in causing chaos it's me
okay they need I don't think they do I
think they're going to be phenomenal and
they just overcome difficult situation
so well but if they do exam yeah I mean
I can only spin but I have a great
enthusiasm you know and you have a
People's Choice or that too is that if I
mean they think while performing yeah I
just be like